bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission minute forme je suis Nicolas
votre coach sportif aujourd'hui nous
sommes en compagnie de Jonathan bonjour
je m'appelle
j'espère que vous également vous êtes
prêts derrière vos écrans pour voir le
mouvement qu'on appelle le site up qui
va cibler la sangle abdominale vous
allez venir vous installer sur les
fesses dans un premier temps fléchir les
jambes et placer les plantes de pieds
l'une contre l'autre vous allez allonger
le dos sur le sol et tendre les bras
derrière l'ouverture de genou va vous
permettre de désengager les muscles soit
s'il y a en contactant les abdominaux
vous allez monter et venir toucher au
niveau des pieds
vous inspirez et vous expirez pour venir
contracter la sangle abdominale
très Jonathan à toi
installe-toi plante de pieds lune contre
l'autre ok l'objectif vraiment d'ouvrir
vraiment ses genoux pour le pas engager
les muscles des hanches allonge-toi et
dans tes bras
vous allez placer les bras vraiment au
dessus de la tête et faites une grosse
contraction musculaire pour pouvoir
basculer en avant c'est parti
très bien
pour la plupart des exercices
d'abdominaux je vous conseille je vous
préconise d'effectuer des séries assez
longues pour avoir une bonne tension une
bonne fatigue musculaire pour avoir des
résultats beaucoup plus rapide comment
ça va Jonathan
ça commence à brûler comment on fait
deux de plus s'il te plaît
allez respire
ok super tu peux t'arrêter comment tu te
sens très bien mais ça travaille
j'espère vous allez sentir la même chose
que je l'attaque chez vous je vais vous
montrer maintenant l'étirement
correspondant cet exercice alors vous
allez venir vous installer sur le ventre
placez les coudes juste à l'extérieur
des épaules joignez les phalanges vous
allez lever au maximum la poitrine
cambrée le dos et tirer les coudes vers
vous pour avoir un maximum d'allongement
au niveau des grands droits
pour respirer vous maintenez la position
entre 20 et 30 secondes
allez vas-y vous venez vous installer
sur le ventre comme elle le fait joignez
les points les coudes en arrière vous
levez la poitrine et vous reculez au
maximum les épaules tu vas sentir
vraiment au niveau du ventre que ça tire
on s'est respirait profondément
et tu relâches très bien jonatal tu peux
te redresser super bah tu as bien bossé
je te remercie en tout cas j'espère que
c'est pas trop fait souffrir bon super
j'espère que vous allez sentir cet
exercice chez vous pensez à ces
étirements également après avoir
effectué vos séries d'abdominaux je vous
donne un rendez-vous pour un prochain
épisode de minutes fort merci de nous
avoir suivi à très bientôt setup
entraînez-vous trois à quatre fois par
semaine en effectuant trois à six séries
de 20 à 50 répétitions évitez la
pression sur la tête et fixez les
hanches au sol